and one local father has made it his
life's mission to help cut down on the
number of people taking their own lives
reggie burton knows the issue all too
well his son avery died by suicide
victoria saha joining us now with more
on the story and also advice that burton
has for other parents yesterday's burton
is a parent who knows too well the
heartache he says this is such a
sensitive topic but an important one
that needs to be discussed so families
can recognize the silent cries for help
graduation a momentous time for students
and everyone around them sometimes that
celebration is just a precursor to a
stressful event burton's son avery had
the world ahead of him in may of 2017 he
graduated from unlv with the hopes of
becoming a doctor and then he realized
it wasn't what he actually wanted or at
least he didn't think he wants it and
that's what spurred the major depressive
episode just two months later that
depressive state led avery to take his
own life so this is a kid that was used
to fixing
problems but this was just one problem
that he couldn't solve burton says
although his family was aware that avery
was going through a tough time he says
avery was very good at hiding the extent
of it which he says is a common thing
among those struggling with mental
illness families default to
love they want to try to love the
problem away and what we need to try to
understand and the lesson we learned is
that love's not enough and experts say
it's okay for family and friends to take
that first step to start the
conversation having a really hard
conversation and if there's any notice
any change that the parents notice that
is different from their norm
then you know that's that's an area of
concern and certainly needs to be
addressed a conversation that can
hopefully turn the outcome around the
surviving family members my heart goes
out to them because they have a lot of
questions and not a lot of answers
since avery's death burton says he
started a foundation in his son's name
aimed at helping those struggling you
can find more about the avery burton
foundation on our website at
8newsnow.com ryan